what's going on guys you know with so
many good shows on Netflix nowadays
sometimes I'll forget that there's so
many good shows on network TV and spring
is the time when show's end and go into
hibernation till the fall but what's a
good season finale without a juicy
cliffhanger
here come the 10 best TV cliffhangers
ever by the way since we're talking
about cliffhangers there's going to be
some spoilers number 10 BBC's Sherlock
the Reichenbach Fall the show that
introduced us to Benedict Cumberbatch
also produced one of the most recent
jaw-dropping finales when Sherlock
apparently committed suicide to save the
lives of his right-hand man Watson and
pretty much everyone else he loved
viewers new Sherlock lived but had to
wait two long years to find out how he
did it in the season 3 premiere you know
what maybe you could pick up the pace
Sherlock might help if Benedict
Cumberbatch wasn't in everything
Battlestar Gallactica had one of the
best makeovers in TV history
transforming itself from a cheesy 70
Star Wars ripoff into one of televisions
best dramas the show is full of crazy
season finales including edward james
olmos getting plugged by a Cylon but the
biggest surprise came at the end of
season 2 when the Weasley newly elected
president Baltar settles the human race
on a dreary planet called New Caprica
all of a sudden nose bastard toasters
show up out of nowhere and just like
that the human race has been conquered
on behalf of the people of the Twelve
Colonies I surrender cut two credits the
really frustrating thing about
Battlestar when the season ended you
never knew when it was coming back or if
it was coming back kind of like when my
girlfriend goes to work
anyone remember fringe well you were out
getting laid on Friday nights I was home
watching Fox's pretty good JJ Abrams
show about alternate universes in their
season one finale FBI agent and
supernatural investigator Olivia sets up
a meeting with a mysterious scientist
William Bell she walks out of an
elevator and comes face to face with the
late great Leonard Nimoy but something's
not quite logical why does this
newspaper say something about the new
White House Olivia looks out the window
and the camera zooms out to reveal that
she's in the World Trade Center what is
this crazy alternate reality viewers of
Fringe had to wait months to find out
and binge Watchers of Fringe had to wait
minutes people who've never experienced
life without internet you don't know how
hard television watching used to be our
number seven cliffhanger is an
especially frustrating one because it's
never going to be resolved that's right
it's the episode that had millions
thinking that their Cable had gone out
the series finale of The Sopranos you
got Tony and his family sitting down for
a nice meal meadow is showing us her
superior parallel parking skills journey
playing on the soundtrack mysterious men
coming and going and then
what happened is Tony dead if it was he
shot by a former associate did he have a
heart attack from all those greasy on
your rings that big [ __ ] come back to
life the world will never know don't
stop believin I stopped believing the
moment that screen went to black
speaking of series finale cliffhangers
that were never resolved we'd be remiss
if we didn't mention Twin Peaks David
Lynch's surreal drama was supposedly
about solving murders in a crazy north
western town and delicious pie two more
pieces of this incredible Buy but really
it was about showcasing David Lynch's
kooky characters like the log lady and
that weird dancing little person and FBI
agent Dale Cooper played by Kyle
mcLaughlin now in the final episode of
season two cooper takes a trip to the
black lodge a sinister place full of
David Lynch Ian type things Cooper gets
injured but seemingly returns to reality
only to reveal that he's actually been
possessed by the big bad of the series
killer Bob how's Annie what I do that
every morning when I'm brushing my teeth
at number five comes the granddaddy of
season finale cliffhangers
Dallas's who shot junior Dallas was an
80s primetime soap about rich people who
use ruthless tactics to screw each other
out of money and oil luckily we fixed
that problem in society the most evil
sumbitch in Texas was Larry hagman's jr.
Ewing in the season 3 finale a house
divided jr. basically spent the whole
episode pissing people off Texas style
until he found himself alone at night
and then this happened
for more info on Dallas ask your weird
aunt of course we can't talk about who
shot jr. without its modern equivalent
who shot mr. burns yep somebody in
Springfield finally shoots the old miser
after he blocks out the Sun and everyone
in town as a suspect well I couldn't
possibly solve this mystery can you
Simpsons fans spent an entire summer
trying to figure out whodunit until it
was revealed that it was the baby yep
Maggie Simpson luckily she wasn't
charged with attempted cartoon murder
now Jerry in the wedge is gonna convict
that baby maybe Texas coming in at
number three is the show that
specialized in asking questions that may
or may not have answers lost the season
three finale was a doozy leaving fans in
shock over the loss of fan favorite
Charlie but it saved the biggest shock
for last as it revealed that the
flashbacks to a traumatized poorly
bearded Jack Shepard weren't flashbacks
at all they were flash forwards what hi
jack
we have to go back Kate
we have to go back how do they get off
the island who else made it is everyone
else dead the show would go on to answer
those questions and pretty much nothing
else as loss would go down in history as
perhaps the most front-loaded show of
all time I mean seriously time travel in
a cave come on guys at number two is the
only cliffhanger that happened while the
character was taking a number two
Breaking Bad season 5 shocker gliding
overall things are looking up for
everyone's favorite teacher slash cancer
survivor slash meth kingpin Walter White
but those plans are coming crashing down
around him when his DEA brother-in-law
Hank pops a squat and finds an
incriminating book that finally connects
the dots as we see him realize that his
brother-in-law is the man that he's been
chasing all along ww you figure that it
Walter White you got me
seriously Heisenberg who leaves an
incriminating book next to the [ __ ]
we're here finally the number one
television cliffhanger on our list it
can be summed up in three words mr. warm
fire that's right Star Trek The Next
Generation produced one of the all-time
greatest season finales when Captain
Picard was abducted and assimilated by
the Borg first officer William Riker
orders the enterprise to destroy the
Borg ship with a massive space weapon
which would kill their beloved captain
and ensure the series would have 100
percent less Earl Grey tea okay and 100%
more trombone playing Trek fans waited
nervously for an entire summer to see if
Picard would bite the space bullet
before the season four premiere where
the weapon failed but the enterprise was
able to rescue their captain this
assured us of years more of Picard in
command and years more of Riker's
sitting down like this dr. Pulaski is
being shown to her quarters we're ready
to get underway I wish I could be a fly
on the wall the day he came up with that
he was like aha this will be my thing
well that was fun and educational
are there any cliffhangers that we Nick
Mundy's here hey Hal hey Nick why are
you here well I just will let you know
and the screen junkie fans know that my
new Comedy Central show nothing to
report is now available online comedy
central.com and their YouTube channel
Comedy Central or leave below and are
you in it with anybody
yes WWE Superstar Chris Jericho that's
reason enough to tune in Nick Mundy get
the [ __ ] out of here Thanks so what we
leave out what's the best TV cliffhanger
in your opinion let us know in the
comments section below tell us why and
the best answer we'll send you a screen
junkies t-shirt I want to thank you guys
for watching I'm Hal rod Nick hit me up
on Twitter bye-bye han Solo says we're
home to for all you
is the Millennium Falcon it part of is
it is it sitting in that sand from that
giant battle because it looks done by a
scavenger found by a scavenger